we start off with peace and this is our
sincere intention for everybody to
establish peace in their life but how
can you have peace if you don't know the
purpose of life if you don't know why
you've been created my next guest has
been touring the whole world sharing the
purpose of life
the purpose of life with the people
but how do you share this purpose of
life if you're not giving what we feel
is that invitation we're going to be
talking about the importance of this
invitation the invitation that will give
you peace prosperity success in this
life and success in the next life my
guest
when we come back here on the dean show
he's going to share to us the importance
of giving this
invitation the legacy of this invitation
my next guest here on the dean show i'm
excited
and i'm sure you are all so you've been
waiting for this moment
when we come back here on the d show sit
tight
this is
this is
now time is limited thank you very much
for finding the time know you're very
busy individual you turn the touring the
world as i mentioned sharing the purpose
of life with the people
you used to be a former christian not to
go too deeply into your past but
this is true you used to be a christian
then you accepted this beautiful way of
life yeah that is true as a matter of
fact um i don't say to people i used to
be a christian
the values of loving jesus christ and
relating to the mission of jesus christ
and the principles of the life of jesus
christ i've maintained that
as far as i'm concerned so i think i got
the best uh out of christianity as we
want to call it that
i got the best out of that by becoming
muslim
so when i meet christians i say to them
that i still carry the values and
principles of loving jesus christ and
perhaps maybe more than people who call
themselves christians now you said an
arabic word you said muslim was we we
probably say i mean is it true that
jesus was a muslim
absolutely the word muslim name the one
who submits to almighty god and the
mandate or the scripture or the
revelation that god sent so all the
prophets abraham moses david solomon
isaac ismail
jesus christ and of course the prophet
muhammad peace and bless me upon him
they were the best of those that
submitted so to submit means muslim and
uh islam means submission so based upon
that uh a basic uh principle and
definition of course the prophets were
all muslims and we're following them so
we're muslims so are you safe to say
also that you're worshiping the god that
jesus worshiped the god that jesus
prostrated to the god that jesus peace
be upon him called upon of course i mean
this is the god of the creator the the
god who is the creator of the heavens
and earth
and the only one who has capacity to
create
uh who creates
the creation
and you know the creation is not creator
and the creators not the creation so
jesus christ certainly was the son of
mary nobody can doubt that so he was
part of the creation
now those that want to deify and make
god a man a man a god that's a different
historical phenomena
but certainly it's the same god that
we're worshiping now the purpose of life
that's the crucial question let me tell
you a a true story okay myself i'm also
trying to
break the ice with people get to know
them and share the purpose of life tried
to have them think
now i was at the home depot dealer you
know the home depot do you have it in
your parts
sure so i i kind of established a report
with one of the people working there and
after seeing him
several times you know i just come see
him the first time say hey have you
considered the purpose of life no you
think i'm crazy or something but after
he saw you know that you know i i'm just
an average person coming or asking talk
making you know small talk after maybe
after half a dozen times of seeing me
and having small talk conversations i
dropped in his ear we somehow led in
that direction and i thought you know
what i'll bring it up you do this all
the time you you actually have thousands
that come to listen to you but it seemed
like i was trying to give this
invitation just for him to consider it i
wasn't trying to proselytize and try to
push my beliefs on him but just to have
him consider
think about it and it seemed like the
next time i showed up at that home depot
i mean he it seemed like i had i had
brought up a question
that was just something
it was real heavy
talk to me did we want to learn from
from your experiences and you know the
importance of giving this message this
invitation and how we can be more
sensitive to the people around us the
culture and the best way to approach
this issue of having people consider the
purpose of life please talk to us [ __ ]
well eddie you know i'd like to just say
to yourself and say to your
television audience
that
the question the great question the
central question
about life
is this objective
not just its end or its beginning but
it's objective
and the objective of life
is spelled out
by understanding its purpose
and if you don't understand the purpose
of life it doesn't matter what you
acquired in life it doesn't matter what
people say about you in life but if you
don't know the purpose it means that you
didn't consider the end
you didn't consider the final value
and so what i've learned to do by
appreciating myself is that when i meet
people not to talk about religion
you know let's talk about politics
not to talk about things that divide us
and put us on different sides of the
aisle but talk about a theme that
everyone can relate to
whether it's time
whether it's weather
whether it's values
principles
of the economy
and then relate that to purpose
because then people can understand that
you're able to make relevant almost any
subject
and in the course of doing that i ask
people have you ever considered
your purpose in life
and you'll be surprised
people are
they're stunted
they're startled
they get confused if they're
intellectual all of a sudden they become
cloudy
and they ask what do you mean by that
well it's a simple question
have you considered your purpose in life
why are you here
you know is there a mandate
that you carry
your beliefs and your values how do they
fit into that purpose and all of a
sudden you find that most people never
really gave it consideration because
it's not a subject in school
it doesn't relate directly towards
religion or or faith or
philosophy or academics it's an inner
question
uh it's a question of the heart a
question of the mind uh it speaks to the
kind of person that you are it sorts is
sort of uh
begins to dictate even
how you act how you behave
how you think how you interact with
other people
so i say to the audience the world
audience your studio audience uh i say
to people that we need to take the time
to consider our purpose in life and when
we consider our purpose in life then
you'll find out it's an even plane you
can even start all over again you don't
have to be born again
you just reassess yourself and then when
you reassess yourself you may find that
you need to make some adjustments to
change where you're heading because
you're going to wind up
you're going to wind up in a place based
upon what you're doing
if you're riding a bicycle you're not
going to wind up in a place where plane
lands you know where planes land
you know if you um if you're doing bling
bling if that's your branding if your
branding is bling bling you're not going
to wind up on the top of society so
purpose almost dictates
where you're going to wind up at
literally even after this life you know
like after life or life hereafter or
hereafter or after here
uh the way you interpret purpose
sort of dictates where you're going to
be head i mean in your inter personal
relationships whether with wife or
children and other people the values
that um that you personify has something
to do with purpose
so i think that this theme purpose is so
profound uh it's like our nose on our
face
uh we look at it every day uh but we
don't even sometimes we miss it
so if we reconsider purpose each one of
us whether we are hindu or buddhist or
christian or muslim or mias or deus or
whatever we are
put purpose in there and begin that
purpose it may reorientate your life
even a small amount shake we're going to
take a break and we'll be right back
sit tight
ya
when the outside everything looks good
you see the hundred thousand dollar cars
you see a lot of diamonds you see a lot
of females and they think that this is
you know this is the life this is this
is like you know paradise right here on
earth
it's not anyone's job to go into
someone's heart and change their heart
your job is to tell people what the
truth is and the reality of it is while
we're sitting here i'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease
secure was
free to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
afraid to is alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if a lie
is by messiah i am not afraid to stand
alone
i am not afraid to stand alone
now
we're talking about purpose crucial
question
and you have toured the world you've
given hundreds of lectures on this very
topic is this correct
well i was going to say thousands of
lectures thousands of lectures yes and a
lot of
non-muslims
potential muslims have accepted this way
of life the way of life of jesus moses
abraham all the messengers of god that
complete and total
submission to the one god not to his
creation but to the creator is this true
that so many we we've seen
you know dozens of people lined up after
they've listened to your presentation by
the grace of the creator of the heavens
and earth and they've accepted this
beautiful way of life you talk about
this well you know uh eddie to be honest
with you um i'd like to sort of
de-personify um uh de-personalize
uh the issue
uh by saying that we see people every
morning lined up in mcdonald's
why because it's a brand it's not that
the food is good it's just that the
branding is in their minds and they line
up for it every day starbucks
mcdonald's burger king pizza hut it's
not something phenomenal
it's something that people need they
identify with and they fit into that
pattern of their lives and what i have
found is that when you speak to people's
hearts and minds
not with the objective of their being
become muslim but maybe adding value to
their life they appreciate it and not
only do they appreciate it later on but
some of them appreciate it right away
and you get reactions from people almost
immediately
and so uh when you see people accepting
islam at the end of a lecture or
presentation that i do it's not sheikha
yasin
it's that i've switched on something
inside of them that they didn't identify
before and when it's switched on uh they
feel good
uh
a glow comes you know um they become a
bit naturally inebriated
they become motivated they do some soul
searching right on the spot and i take
advantage of that by saying to them that
well
we don't know where life ends we don't
know where the interruption comes and
whatever you're going to bear witness to
whatever you're going to testify to
it's going to be
written on a tablet uh that's going to
set your values and your balance it's
going to dictate where you're going to
arrive at and so you should testify now
because you don't know if you're going
to speak if you're going to wake up
tomorrow and people do
they embrace islam on the spot
in the past 15 years the purpose of life
foundation has been instrumental
in
facilitating people to enter islam
and my colleagues tell me that the
figure is somewhere around 38 000 that's
what i'm told
however that figure is a bit
deceptive or misleading
because in fact a figure that i'd rather
give to the audience and say to people
is that for every one person that have
accepted islam
there's another 10 they didn't accept
islam they didn't embrace islam but they
have accepted the values and they came
from a distant point to a closer point
they came from being perhaps enemies in
confrontation or
about islam to become allies and so if
we look at that figure the 38 000
and another 10 people who didn't enter
islam but they might be family they
might be a colleague co-worker um a
family member uh there might be a
neighbor
who is no longer confused about islam
who is no longer apprehensive about
muslims
who understands the values so they have
embraced the values but they haven't
embraced islam that's an ally so that's
like 38 that's like 380 000.
so that's the figure we like to deal
with to give muslims the understanding
that we have a chance
to touch the lives of the american
people and people around the world
positively
secondly when you touch their lives in
that way
their lives no longer they cannot be the
same again
and so we're about touching lives
touching hearts and if some people's
minds and hearts and lives are touched
and they become muslims the benefit is
theirs uh and and also ours we see the
residual residual from god you know when
somebody enters islam it's like salesmen
we get our percentage yes it's a
residual that'll be on our scales on a
day of judgment uh for them they're the
greatest winners because they've been
relieved of their sins and now they have
become muslims and now they can make
something better of their uh they can
see their purpose in life and they can
do something better with their lives we
talked about now the purpose of life and
the importance of
bringing people to to to consider this
and so many people that when when they
listen to your lectures and they
consider this they accept this wonderful
way of life
but now let's talk about the invitation
the invitation is crucial and many
muslims
who are living islam
they're not sharing this invitation can
you talk about in arabic it's called
dawah the importance of sharing this
message this message that brings peace
to a person's life that brings happiness
and success the importance of sharing
the purpose of life with humanity
well you know it's uh it's it's very
natural uh uh when you think about it
and i'd like to use the analogy uh
because analogies sometimes get points
across quicker than doctrine
um
you know out of uh some 180
transnational companies in the world
today about 120 are american companies
now that needs to be explained put into
context
this is because americans
have no problem in promoting their goods
and services
they believe that their goods and
services are the best and they go
everywhere in the world and say i'm an
american and their goods and services
are embraced by people all over the
world if a muslim believes
that their faith system and their values
is the best that the world has to offer
why wouldn't they share that with
another human being
and if they're not doing that then
there's probably some psychological or
personal
uh
deficits that they have
maybe they have a conflict in their
self-esteem maybe they're socially
dysfunctional maybe they're afraid and
all of those uh psychological uh um
we can call it
uh psychological barriers uh prevent us
from delivering this message and our
prophet muhammad peace and blessed me
upon him his main mandate from god was
to deliver the message he was the
messenger of allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam so if muslims are muslims by
culture or they're muslims uh by just
by birth if they're muslims just uh by
virtue of uh saying the words and being
muslim and by performing the prayers and
so forth who cares about that nobody
knows what we do inside the masjid
nobody knows what we do inside our homes
what people understand is the behavior
what people understand is the character
what people understand is the residual
the final product
and if people are proud about the
products and services that they
represent they speak to the world about
it and so when we give darwin the
invitation to islam we're not inviting
people to ourselves we're not inviting
people to muslims we're inviting people
to islam submission to the one god we're
inviting people to a premise of life
that will give them benefit in this life
and also in the hereafter so why
wouldn't people do that and if they
don't do that
well they are the losers
uh and then those of us who have adopted
that mode
of responsibility and that's what it is
it's a social responsibility that we
have to what deliver the message because
if we don't deliver the message then
we're like an ambassador that was sent
out from the king
and we arrived in a place to deliver a
message on behalf of the king and we got
so engrossed with the society that we
were sent to we forgot to deliver the
message so we muslims have been sent by
the king of the heavens and the earth
and we are ambassadors to deliver this
message and we cannot forget uh our
mission statement before we go to break
just if you can help clarify you
mentioned something about
the the person's mind becomes a little
clouded
but why is it when we talk about sports
when we talk about football baseball we
talk about the opposite gender and
dating and you know facebook and all
these other things that are out there
people you know you can carry on a
conversation but sometimes usually like
this individual at home depot
real life example you bring up
this crucial question and the person's
mind becomes clouded why do you think
this is uh well it's it's a natural
natural um psychological knee jerk we
call it knee jerk yes knee jerk it's
like um i don't know if you took psycho
psychology one-on-one and the whole um
analogy of pavlov's pavlov's uh
salivating dog
that when you think about food you start
salivating when you look at the golden
arches of uh of mcdonald's you start to
salivate
so this is something natural inherent in
the human being and so people
when they talk about sports or girls
talking about boys and boys about girls
and
whatever it is that people feel
motivated about and whatever they have a
natural ability to communicate
and talk about my team okay and to talk
about it real enthusiastically but when
it comes to the issue of their
faith-based principles if they're not
clear about that they don't salivate
they're not motivated and therefore they
start talking about it in a very
clinical way they become reactionary so
you know we need to do this in a very
natural way just like fish swim and
birds fly
and uh uh and if we do that people will
receive it in the same way and allah
knows best we're gonna take another
break right back with more we're here
with sheikh khalid yasin and the dean
shall sit tight right back i am not
afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is
if a lie is by messiah i am not afraid
to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is
come and see what everyone's talking
about
but the argument here is that god out of
his love
because in all honesty if you really
wanted to do something
you're going to find a way where there's
a will there's a way absolutely
there are a few problems here
why were people of generations and
generations and generations being told
to worship one god
ask that god for forgiveness ask him for
for salvation seek his mercy no one
else's
so he picked up the quran
which is the last and final testament
the last and final revelation
i was 16 years eight years in active
reserves and eight years active duty
but uh the bottom line is that i'm an
ophthalmologist i'm a
specialist in cataracts and refractive
surgery i'm the medical director of the
major icelanders
these are not god
god is the one who created everything in
this universe that's the one i'm going
to worship
and prostrate to how can you go wrong
doing that
you don't believe in them you're out of
islam
top 10 reasons why jesus cannot be god
let's get right to it cannot be god
number 10 number 10
back here on the dean show with sheikh
khalid you have seen purpose of life
crucial question you got to get
motivated to give the invitation to have
people reflect and consider the purpose
of life before death it's a reality it's
coming isn't it yes so what would you
feel
is a
positive way a natural way a way that we
can get more people to consider this
we can get more people to consider the
purpose of life before that ultimate
reality hits
death and the grave
and then bye bye to all the
baseball football and all these other
things that
people were consumed with give us some
advice shay please
well
eddie i think that
talking to human beings about the
purpose of life or
trying to get people to consider or to
share that value
it should come naturally
i think that if i'm on a train or a bus
or
uh
in a cafe or in a school or and i'm
talking to a person
we talk about the weather
we talk about the economy and we have to
make relevant
uh the value systems regardless of who
we're talking to and what we're talking
about
the other thing is that uh we need to
basically um put into that when people
see a value in something they want what
is valuable nobody wants what is
invaluable
secondly people want what is
contemporary they don't want what is old
they they can appreciate nostalgia
but they want what is modern what is
contemporary what is relevant today
and so in the course of my interaction
with people generally i try to make
relevant to them the value of life the
principles of life
and i get them to agree to to have
consensus about those values
and to want those values and that we
want the same values when i get them to
agree to that then i ask them so how can
you sort of ensure
that you're going to become a
beneficiary of those values when they're
not clear about it i say well let me
make a proposition to you and people
like propositions
and not
things that
we order them to do you know we try to
give them close-in propositions no we
give them open propositions and we say
consider this here we say think about
this here and the value that god says in
one place in the quran it says god says
and i'll just translate it quickly he
says can i invite you to a business or a
proposal that will save you from a
grievous chastisement and so i think
that since life ends
in such an abrupt way
we need to say to people that suppose i
suppose i give you a value or suggestion
that may help you to understand the
other side of life the continuation of
life and also add value to the life that
you have do you think they will be
motivated to listen of course they would
and we haven't said a word about islam
or the quran or the prophet muhammad no
arabic terminologies or no religious
terminologies we've just given them a
straightforward proposal that all human
beings psychologically are receptive to
and god knows best we're out of time but
just for the millions of viewers that
are out there there are many who
are reflecting about this and
you know what they just turned the
channel and they're catching us here
they might have gotten away from all the
different other distractions and now you
have their attention
what would you have this person consider
now we just have a few few seconds left
it's a heart to heart with that sincere
soul searcher out there who really wants
to know what the purpose of life is why
he's been created where is he going when
he dies talk to him please sure yes
i'd like to just say to the studio
audience wherever you are in the world
or this great country of america that
each one of us need to think about the
shortness of life at the end of the day
life is a capsule of time
uh and you don't control time
if god had any power over his creatures
at all it would be time and so we don't
know when time is up therefore we have
to use our time properly we have to
consider the power and the benefit of
time and when life is over it's over
it's wrapped up it's packaged and you
only have your deeds it's only your
deeds it's not what you have it's not
what you have wished for or hoped for
it's your deeds and so on the day of
judgment you'll have your deeds to speak
for you and we ask almighty god to cause
all of us to be cognizant of that and to
be the beneficiaries of our time with
good deeds and with good deeds uh we'll
find that good breeds good and there's
no other reward for good other than good
i want to just thank you so very much
for being here at the dean's show and we
want to be able to come back and forth
many different times we'd love to have
you good breed's good i like that the
way that we can we started with peace we
peace that's correct brother thank you
very much god almighty the creator
rewards you for taking the time to be
with us thank you so much brother thank
you and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the dean's show
purpose of life
we really want you to consider it for
some
reason that you have tuned on and you
got to just get a little bit of a taste
of we were talking about if you like
what we have to say continue to tune
back here to the dean show continue to
reflect
before
the end of life
approaches and as the sheikh was saying
as our guest was saying time is all we
have so we need to make the best out of
our time
doing good breeds good and we're
inviting you to do the ultimate good and
that's to establish a relationship with
the one creator who created you
beseech his help
call upon him alone the same god that
jesus called upon the same god that
abraham noah moses all the messengers of
god
they sought to
know the purpose of life from the
creator of life the one god
thank you for tuning in to the dean show
we hope that you can join us again next
time until then peace be unto you
a lot of you out there are in the exact
same position he said i would never give
up worshipping god as one i would never
give up spreading this message i hope
that you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now
yeah they know they got to change they
know they got to do good but they don't
do the good why is this [ __ ]
the ranking of the 100 most influential
men in the history of the world laziness
the reality of life usually doesn't
sink in
until tragedy comes you know this is
when you find people yeah yeah okay tell
me about it
you get a few bad people the media grabs
a hold of that and spends it the way
they want to
and in it he puts muhammad as number one
he said no human being
had more influence
one of the amazing things about islam
that everyone should know is that we are
the only other religion that is a tenant
of faith that you must believe in jesus
christ and everything that he did or you
cannot be a muslim if that is missing if
you say that you do not believe in jesus
you have stepped outside of islam you
cannot be a muslim is attending our
faith to
to believe in and love jesus christ
these are not god
god is the one who created everything in
his universe that's the one i'm gonna
worship
and prostrate to how can you go wrong
doing that
you don't believe in them you're out of
islam
top 10 reasons why jesus cannot be god
let's get right to it cannot be god
number 10 number 10.
you'll be glad you did
you